honestly but I'm saying from my
experience
um they people have paid and I've been
on dates and I've never spoke to a
person again after and they spent a lot
of money do you know what I mean you're
not valuing their time and money because
you think that every single one of them
that's spending that money whether it's
a hundred pound or 200 pounds you think
all of them have got it there's some man
that probably have taken you out on date
and that's their loss probably but I
would never know exactly so then but
you're still not respecting their money
I I don't think about it like that
exactly because you're so you're still
saying that you you can't give them too
much but they're spending 200 pounds on
you on a first date but I don't think
the way guys go on they act like money's
nothing to them and they and you know
what I mean so why would I be so
conscious like unless I love you and I
know about your financial situation
it'll be complete okay but this is the
thing you're just not appreciative
because you're saying no you're not I'm
listening to you speak
you come off appreciative to anyone
I'm an ungrateful person okay but I'm
listening to you speak